well bits
251
eight home runs did not have a hit last
night and he starts tonight putting this
one into the gap in right center field
picked up by cattell martay and into
second base with his 19th double of the
season is mookie bets and that's how the
game begins
that could have easily been a ground out
but he stays with it stays down and in
his legs and drives that ball to right
center and it doesn't have to get to the
wall for mookie to get two
2-1 pitch coming to will smith that's it
second
two out
and will gets it in the air right field
and deep it is carrying to the wall it
is gone
a two-run home run will smith
and the dodgers jump out in front two
nothing
tip of the hat to will smith but this is
the difference between being a ground
ball pitcher and making your mistakes
below the knee or a ground ball pitcher
and making your mistakes up when you
make them up they are just flat and easy
to barrel up
even if it has movement it stays on the
barrel and will smith takes that moving
fastball and plants it out there in
right field
david smith gave it all he had
mckinstry
to left center in a base hit
one out single for zach his 25th hit of
the year
[Applause]
mueller puts it down nicely
[Applause]
fourth sacrifice bun of the year for
bueller that moves mckinstry into
scoring position two down
[Music]
do you believe your catcher all the time
try to do that
going the other way is lux that's down
for a hit
mckinstry rumbling home he will score
three-nothing dodgers on a two-out rbi
single for gavin lux
[Applause]
this is the maturity
maturing of a young hitter
just not trying to do too much take the
pitch where it's thrown a tailing up
fastball took it right where the
movement was going
and enough speed for mckinstry to score
because you're off at the crack of the
bat with two outs oh just gotten word
from the diamondbacks carson kelly who
was hit on the right risk is out with a
fractured right wrist what else can
happen to this ball
[Music]
so baby's taking full advantage of his
opportunities
what a play by walker they get one and
that's it
christian walker kept that ball from
getting up the line
a tremendous play at first by christian
shows some pretty good hops right there
unfortunately his sidearm throw to nick
ahmed at second base was a little off
line and low trying to avoid the runner
going to second base
and they can only get the force play
there at second
little wobble here from ahmed on the
transfer
mueller has hit a battery he's walked a
banner he's got four strikeouts
diamondbacks last night held the three
hits have none so far tonight got him
that was outstanding right there with
the curveball the fifth strikeout for
bueller
there's a strikeout and did he get him
though and martay's able to get to
second base
but walker goes down looking two on the
ground right side knocked down by baby
and bueller to the bag in time damn
still
walker bueller
who threw four innings has struck out
six walked to hit a batter and has yet
to give up a base hit
to deep first
baby
throws a strike to buehler for the out a
little more of that weak contact one
gone here's pavon smith the right
fielder
curveball got him strike three fiona
really has the curveball going and he is
baffling these arizona hitters tonight
in the air to right field and there is
mckinstry to grab it for the out another
easy inning for buehler and the bases
are full of dodgers
three walks in the inning turner coming
in and it's into right center field it's
gonna clear the basis it gets past smith
betts comes in to score
and right behind him is lux it's a bases
clearing double and the dodgers lead it
six nothing justin turner with a three
rbi hit walker bueller is working on a
no hitter here threw five innings
he's walked to he's hit a batter he has
struck out seven he's got a six-nothing
lead this one in play and baby will
handle it three unassisted one down
credit is returned for the first stop
here on the sixth and that'll bring up
rojas one two
got him looking
breaking ball and rojas strikes out he
doesn't like it he's chirping with doug
evans two down for the diamondbacks
strikeout number eight for bueller
payoff pitch
oh grounder left side that'll be charged
by lux throws and it's in time to get
him
for bueller who's got a no-hitter
through six the bases are loaded for
bets maria delivering the 1-2
and this ball is lifted in the air the
left back is peralta
and he will make the grab
scoring on the play
is aj pollock and it's seven to nothing
sacrifice fly on rbi for bets he's got a
no-hitter through six he has struck out
eight he's in the driver's seat has been
since pitch number one got him
strikeout number nine for buehler the
gas is looking good this late in the
ball game and there is strikeout number
ten
and walker builder appears to be getting
stronger as the game is going on and a
ground ball at first
andy burns will take it himself it's 12
in a row
six outs away from a no-hitter a base
hit into right field off the bat of
turner two out chris taylor coming up
and taylor hits a high fly ball left
fifth gun a home run
chris taylor
makes it
nine nothing
a two-run shot tenth home run for taylor
walker bueller starts the bottom of the
eighth inning against david peralta
bueller has retired the last 12 men in a
row 15 of the last 16.
and a line drive base hit and there goes
the no hitter david peralta breaks up
walker builders
tremendous night dreams of a no-no
are gone
there goes smith on strikes that's
strikeout number 11
for bueller
walker bueller will come out after 108
pitches to a standing ovation on the
road what a night for bueller sounds
like a home game mitch white is now on
in relief against the pitch hitter tim
lacastro the castro punches it into
right field they're going to send
peralta here's the throw
he's in there
on the no hit or gone shutout gone
divac's on the board
and hits it deep to left center that
slicing away from mookie becks and it's
off the wall
ahmed is home la castro flying around
third it's a two-run double for cattell
marte well he got no hit through seven
suddenly four hits in the eighth
left-hander garrett clevenger will be
tasked to wrap this one up tonight the
diamondbacks down to their last out it's
a ball game it's a dodger w
in phoenix
9-3 final score clevenger wraps it up
walker bueller takes a no-hitter into
the eighth inning